Let's think about the first scenario.
We know that we are recording our voice here in this first scene,
or the record sounds view controller.
But we will need that recorded file in here in the second scene, or
in the Play Sounds View Controller.
We will definitely need to pass that audio file onto the second scene.
Now if you look in the storyboard, we can see that these two scenes,
they're connected to each other.
This means that every time you press the stop button,
we move on to the second scene.
This doesn't really give us the opportunity to pass the audio file we
recorded in here,
inside the Record Sounds View Controller to Play Sounds View Controller.
To change this, I will select the Segue and then hit Delete on my keyboard.
Now if I try to build a project, Xcode will complain that
the second scene is abandoned and that there is no way of reaching it.
I can see that message right here, by clicking this triangle.
It says that this scene is unreachable due to a lack of entry point.
To fix this, I will connect two view controllers.
I will select this first view controller, then press and
hold Ctrl on my keyboard, and
start dragging from this View Controller to the second one, and then let go.
Here I will select the option Show one more time.
Now that these two are connected, I can invoke a function called performSegue(),
from somewhere inside my code to actually trigger this segue.
And while I do that, I can pass the audio file from this view
controller to this view controller and I can do all of that from inside my code.
I will do this exercise in the next few videos.
For now, let me just select the segue and give it a name.
I will slide out the utility area and
under Attributes Inspector I will give this segue a name or an identifier.
Let me call it stopRecording.
All right.
Let's go back out slides and tackle the second scenario.
This situation talks about what would happen if we start to
play an audio conversation that has not been fully processed by the phone yet.
To understand that, we need to understand something called Delegate in iOS.
Now before we jump into what this means in iOS,
I want you to think about what this word means in simple english.
So here is the question one more time.
What comes to mind when I say the word delegate.
Enter your response in this box.